all right clap what it do
welcome to Rio for sure it's a show we
made about things you do when you grow
up one of the things you do when you
grow up is fall in love so today we have
three different pieces we made about
different people falling in love the
first one features this guy he's Zack
hey so I want to do that gonna be your
catchphrase there's an article that went
viral about set of questions researchers
developed a few years ago the idea is
you can take two people and they'll sit
down and ask these 36 questions and
through that process they'll fall in
love with each other
we had Zack answer them with three
different people that he had three
different relationships with and we want
to see like did it work did he fall in
love with any of them one of the people
was a girl that he was already friends
with and thinks just cute yeah I mean
she's a cute girl you think she's cute
yeah I mean but I mean just Ryan you
think she's cute right yeah he's
attractive she's cute yeah I thought you
just you said pick a kick front layer do
you feel non-committal about saying your
track I just think I think I think that
she's just a cute person yes let's feel
ya I'm gonna try to try that's fun to
say and so now we're gonna watch some of
the footage Oh crazy all right you ready
- okay gonna do this quiz my perfect day
would involve a bunch of kittens hairy
not see already we can't fall in love
cuz I say I like kittens and she doesn't
I feel like maybe that's your problem
he's there's a lot of deal-breakers I'm
pinky me and my dad had a terrible
because he was drinking me a terrible
relationship my name is Cheyenne and a
lot of time I was called crying cuz I
cried a lot it's a pretty clever
nickname anytime she's opening herself
to me I make I make a weird face and
then make a joke about it that's I think
a thing that she should work on even
weather have a great relationship I love
my mom she's been like a constant in my
life
that's helped me love it and it's so
cute
as a moment yeah she's like look at the
way she's looking at you like there's
clear chemistry I mean you talk about
how much you love your mom and girls
like it apparently she agrees absolutely
tell your partner what you like about
them be very honest this time saying
things you might not say someone you've
just sent again I think you're fun
then you're super cute you're just like
like your personality wise and looks
wise you're just like a fun disarming
person to be around
you're just a very smart a nice person
to be around and easy to talk to good
joking around about things but being
serious when you need to be serious
she said I'm serious when I need to be
serious you could find love through this
sec with all yours what about you I'm
only doing it with you so I'm in love
with you
love's a strong word yeah I mean like
with you alright I like you right
I like Terry Gross it was a good way to
like get to know each other yeah yeah I
liked it I think we should hug yourself
yeah all right it feels like you are
totally about to ask her out and feels
like she would say yes in that moment do
you see that watching it what we both
kind of agreeing is that like if the
cameras weren't if we were like at home
doing this quiz and the cameras weren't
rolling we probably would have made out
at the end of the video realistically
and then there's also that like feeling
like ëthe does she's a friend keep it as
a friend who cares you could you're
looking for love that's who cares yeah
we're gonna take a quick break from
Zach's experiment and we're gonna watch
a video about a couple in love who work
together but it's not like a normal kind
of working together
what kind of working is it let's find
out the CEO you're looking okay was it
my Navy pants I'm gonna pick the five
girls they think look the best and
they're gonna call them out and they're
gonna stand in a row and then do these
ones together the same exact pose that
came up the first 30 seconds they're in
the middle that's the best spot that
means they're comparing everyone against
the person in the middle you're not in
the middle and you're pushed to the
outside kind of [ __ ] every morning you
wake up and you like discover a new vein
or a new line or you're just that much
leaner so it's fun but it gets to a
point which is like gonna be Saturday
where you
mr. direct contact with pills or water
let me get morons
that was a new stove
I'm just like a tomboy I always have
been I like track pants and buns on the
top of my head mm-hmm but it is fun to
get girly every now and then it's easy
to forget to have balance to have fun
and makes it extra hard when you're in a
relationship okay so that's Justin
tonight on our wedding day laying here
feeling sticky on our anniversary
reflecting about how do Sh like I've
been this prep I thought I was doing a
good job balancing life the gym and my
work but thinking back I've actually
truly liked a big D about it Justin got
the shaft and even though I love the gym
the gym without him is nothing but a
bunch of metal and Bo we're best friends
and have so much fun together and party
together laugh together get high
together go eat 25 pounds of food and
like food coma ourselves together and
yeah i was just neglecting the fun stuff
and the stuff that makes our
relationship our relationship it look
like I'm from Texas this is the meanest
I've seen your face yeah it's weird
you still look adorable though the more
carb you eat the more [ __ ] up your
face looks but the better your body
looks you
extra mineral hey guys happy Valentine's
Day
yeah yeah yeah out of it yeah easy way
out I plan I know but shots yeah messes
with your head a little bit like you
have to have balance you have to have
fun there's more to life than just the
gym and just being lean and having abs
I went up front of Mike what are you
guys looking at everyone's there
laughter look at me the whole done 16
weeks of training for 16 seconds of oh
just like a joke he could have been
maybe she was too hard for the physique
and then they don't really like abs and
my abs are pretty chunky it was just for
fun and that's that's what this is all
about so like it was cool she's not even
comparing herself down to people most
people shouldn't compare themselves to
her and that's how it always should be
so you don't care that's cool Henry
wanted me to get a stranger so I went on
tinder and I just started swiping I
found this girl Maddy anyone that you
like give a weird proposition to on
tinder as your opening line and they're
like yeah sounds fun let's do it I'm
like all right yeah I should meet you
you seem cool if you could wake up
tomorrow having gained any one quality
or ability what would it be I always
want to know what people are thinking
about me I just want like blind
confidence I feel like if I just were
like you know I start with insecurity
and anxiety a lot so I feel like if I
just were like blindly [ __ ] confident
I could just like I can do anything
maybe it's the package dancer in a
romantic sense I like don't give myself
a chance to get into relationships I
don't think but I would like to but then
I come up with excuses and I put blocks
in my way I've never really really had a
super serious boyfriend like kind of but
for mines which I really don't think you
say you love him to him no and I don't
you know I've never said to anybody in
like a romantic way alternate sharing
something you consider a positive
characteristic of your partner share a
total of five items sorry I know I got a
little information
yeah great laughs thank you yeah you
you've kind eyes I don't mean I'm like a
lion guy yeah kinda is Cornfeld
they're hidden behind glasses no yeah I
got them baby blues so I think also like
and this is unfortunate she was younger
and like I felt a responsibility to be
like appropriate I don't know you know I
don't I think I like kept a distance a
professional distance from her the
entire time don't like it I'm just
saying man I was on a date with a guy
and he said it asked me these deeper
questions I actually I think I'd be like
really cool am I kind of a turn-on
because it means that he's like trying
to get to know me instead of just like
sitting there and like trying to get
laid like ass awkward and like I don't
know complete this sentence I wish I had
someone with whom I could share I
sometimes don't like to like share my
life with eyes like I have one like
there's like times where I'm just like
Jax looking for love I'm looking for
love man uh-huh
in your opinion the 36 questions may be
a little aggressive for a first date but
pretty good we both ended at the same
place where we agreed like this
questionnaire works I went from not
knowing or caring about her at all so
like like I kind of want to see like
where like where she where she gonna be
in a year like what's she gonna do what
job is she gonna get like I I'm invested
in her as you know you guys Facebook
friends or anything now
yeah
we're now gonna watch another video that
Ryan over here made waiver the camera
it's a video based on a post by our
co-worker Kristen who had a really like
a just amazing story about meeting her
boyfriend and falling in love with him
that we wanted to share my name is
Kristen and my boyfriend loves fat women
ironically enough I met my boyfriend
during the thinnest month of my life I
was at a friend's birthday party to bar
when I saw my future boyfriend Brian
from across the room Brian was the type
of guy I spent most of my life pining
after and never getting slim with dark
hair and glasses his jeans torn all the
right places if I had still been at my
heaviest weight I never would have
approached Brian but I was feeling brave
and I walked that crazy all the way to
the other side of the bar and introduced
myself to him there was a three hour
period after Brian first kissed me where
I felt like I could do anything in my
mind I had done the impossible at some
point that night I remember lying next
to him
still feeling unbelievably cocky for my
victory when Brian mentioned you aren't
normally my type oh god I thought is
this the part where he lets me know how
nice he is for throwing my chubby ass a
bone what's normally your type I asked I
like bigger ladies very big ladies
actually he said but I am your type I
thought sadly Brian was attracted to fat
girls and I was one of them
this of course did not take away from
how into Brian I was we started dating
almost immediately and became
inseparable it was also during this time
that I started slowly putting a lot of
weight back on I put on the sundress
that I thought might be a little too
backless for my current weight Brian
however loved the dress maybe even a
little bit too much I spent a lot of
time swatting his hands away from the
open back
I felt happy wearing it beautiful then I
wore it to a bar Brian turned to a
mutual friend of ours and eagerly
drunkenly opined doesn't Kristen look
amazing in that dress the silence that
followed felt like the moment before
someone hits the button on a dunk tank I
realized that too Brian
I did look amazing in that dress because
I looked fat it got to the point where
compliments from Brian were actually
painful to hear every time he said you
look beautiful all I could ever hear was
you look fat
Brian would carefully say I love your
body
because Kristen lives in your body and
the worst part was that the more I poked
at myself the more Brian would poke at
himself too
one morning I saw Brian looking at
himself in the mirror grabbing the small
Pudge from his stomach how many times
had Brian felt like this frustrated
annoyed and helpless as he watched me
tear down a thing he loved I wish I
could say that I'm a hundred percent
okay with myself I'm trying to
understand that just like I am NOT just
a fat girl brian is not just a person
who likes fat girls two years ago I
didn't even realize they made bikinis in
a size 18 turns out that they do and
this year I intend to buy one and wear
it to the beach I will enjoy how excited
that makes Brian's to see me happy in my
own skin I will let him enjoy the thing
that he loves without tearing it down
but most importantly I will work tower
love from me who will always play the
hardest to get
I will floor it as hard as I can and I
will win myself back
you
another person we want Zack to try and
fall in love with was a dude he was
already good friends with yeah keep to
this point I probably seen Keith naked
as many times as any person I've ever
seen naked I've done this quiz with two
women ro and one element I didn't say to
perfect day was it probably ends with
sex that's the thing I couldn't tell
other like when I was with the two girls
I wasn't comfortable saying like my
perfect day probably involves getting
laid you could change anything about the
way you were raised what would it be uh
yeah I think for me our family never
says I love you out loud for some reason
I think that's the only thing that like
I feel earned a lot about Keith that
like questions I wouldn't have asked
things that were there's no reason to
ask but like you do look like you're
falling in love here I was I really
can't see yeah me neither
where where does it stop for you I also
want to say me and the other girls we
took like an hour Keith and I took two
and a half hours
haha Keith and I took forever did I do
this crazy cuz we just had so much fun
look at that look at that laughs I
didn't do that laughs for anyone else
it's got to start with me and I just
need to believe I'm the great person I
hope I am you are an awesome person and
like I want to hang out with you like I
and I'm like Becky wants you to hang out
with me is like what's that doing you
think I was that I think there's like
tons of people who love you and the only
reason like you're not dating someone is
either you know whoever you need to find
as it is I've been found yet or you're
just not opening yourself up to things
that may not be perfect I mean there was
a point where we're Keith and I were
talking and I was about like I almost
said I love you and this is like halfway
through the quiz and I I'm like you know
what I was gonna say it and I said I
love you he said let me back it was a
nice moment I think I already did love
you yeah right now I'm some people
saying I think what I think is good
about this exercise it allows me to
understand more like of where you come
from do you feel like you have each
other more now yes beautiful we all in
this room feeling cool
let's keep him there yeah that's good
what do we stick out to do we sought out
for me to fall in love and I think with
the sample you know it didn't happen and
that's fine but I think it did through
this process allowed me to maybe learn a
little bit about myself and come to a
place where maybe I'm you're more ready
to fall maybe I'm more ready
who would you say you're the most in
love with of these three absolutely
Keith I love that so no doubt in my mind
so [ __ ] adorable
wrap it up now because that's the first
episode of real mature
thanks for watching uh-huh what's your
opening how your on how it is how you do
what it do what it what it there
real mature is produced by the BuzzFeed
IRL team this episode was made by me
Henrik and Ryan be with some help from
Linda Colin made the weightlifting knock
special thanks to Zach Keith
Kristin and biro who made many of the BC
hurt in this episode I'm the least
[ __ ] recharge